je viens une seconde à la tribune après
la très bonne intervention de marc
fesneau et l'excellente intervention de
monsieur le maire de guidel que j'ai
trouvé frappés au coin d'une juste
intelligence
et d'injuste jugement et c'est pas si
fréquent pour qu'on puisse le dire comme
ça
chez vous monsieur le maire
j'ai trouvé ça très très intéressant et
des exemples frappants
je veux simplement dire à quel point
nous sommes heureux d'ouvrir ensemble
cette université de rentrée il ya
environ la moitié
des participants qui sont arrivés et
l'autre moitié qui va arriver je salue
ceux qui viennent de loin
je salue les béarnais qui sont très
nombreux
j'en ai vu quelques uns les autres
finissent le très long périple
monsieur guy tel monsieur le maire
monsieur lacenaire
guidel s'est admirablement place et
c'est un tout petit peu des centres et
je n'ai pas dit que le maire était
décentré
en rien mais mes jeux c'est vrai que
c'est un peu long pour arriver ici et je
me joins aux remerciements que sur ce
thème marc fesneau a indiqué
nous aurons un sujet central
pendant ces trois jours où ces deux
jours et demi ce sujet central c'est
celui de la tente qui est la nôtre et
qui est celle de beaucoup de citoyens
français de la reconstruction du pays
on est tous très insatisfaits de la
succession des pouvoirs dont on a
l'impression que
les annonces ne correspondent jamais à
la réalité que les mots dissimulent les
choses qu'on entend des chiffres qu'on
sait jamais ce qu'on ne sait jamais
apprécié pour savoir s'ils sont vrais ou
pas le
comme je les dis hier soir dans une
émission
vraiment
entendre alors que le premier ministre
s'est exprimé une heure cela nellement
devant l'assemblée nationale
puis qu'il a parlé solennellement car
sur la principale la première chaîne de
télévision au journal de 20 heures
il ne dit rien et c'est le lendemain
matin par hasard au détour d'une
question qu'il annonce
rien moins que la suppression d'une
tranche d'impôt sur le revenu et je
donne rendez vous à tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet on m'expliquera
comment on fait pour supprimer une
tranche d'impôt sur le revenu et en même
temps comme l'a dit françois hollande
pour ne pas augmenter les taux des
autres tranches je voudrais juste
comprendre autrement ça veut dire que la
première la deuxième tranche devient la
première
est qu'on se trouve évidemment avec un
manque à gagner pour le budget de l'état
qui est chiffré à 10 milliards
évidemment il est impossible de trouver
10 milliards je ne sais d'ailleurs pas
comment tu 11,5 milliards et je sais pas
davantage comme ont tous trois milliards
dans un pays qui est exposée au déficit
depuis dix ans
qui sont sans précédent et qui nous
conduisent au bord des pires accidents
on sait que ce soir même on attend la
notation d'une agence qui va
naturellement une fois de plus nous
mettre devant la réalité de notre
situation
et c'est pas les agences qui sont
méchantes pas plus que le médecin qui
vous prend la tension ne crée
d'hypertension
il l'a constate ne la crée pas c'est la
situation dans laquelle nous donc il y a
un profond et coup tout le monde note
doute
profond de défiance sur la manière dont
le pays est gouverné successivement par
les majorités et dont la situation de la
société se dégrade en profondeur pas
seulement dans les chiffres mais dans la
réalité de la vie et du sentiment que
chacun d'entre nous porte chacun d'entre
nous comme père de famille comme mère de
famille comme grands frères et grandes
soeurs grand-père quelquefois on grand
mère porte sur l'avenir de ceux qui nous
sont confiées et dont nous avons la
charge
or nous voyons bien que pour que la
france tienne
avec tant de handicap est temps de
soupçon étant de suspicion alors il faut
qu'il y ait profondément du resort faut
qu'ils aient des potentiels qui sont pas
exploitées il faut qu'il y ait des
choses précieuses qui pour l'instant
sont barrées notre travail c'est cela
c'est de reconstruire la société pour
que ces potentiels puissent apparaître
et s'expriment mais pour qu'il y ait
reconstruction il faut qu'il y ait des
reconstructeurs et notre mission à nous
c'est celle-là et
au sens large sans parler de partis
politiques et d'étiquettes deux parties
le seul lieu démocratique d'où peut
venir aujourd'hui après des expériences
successives au pouvoir
et autant de déceptions le seul lieu
démocratique d'où peut venir le
renouvellement qui doit porter l'esprit
de reconstruction c'est au sens large du
mot le grand espace du centre en france
cet espace pour l'instant est divisé et
je vous le dis sylvain comté il faut
qu'ils s'unissent et ça sera le thème de
la discussion que ce soir nous allons
avoir avec des amis avec jean arthuis en
particulier nous avons besoin de
reconstruire ou de construire le centre
pour reconstruire la france parce que
c'est ça notre obligation comme citoyen
et comme minutes
et j'ajoute un mot
que j'ai très souvent défendu devant
vous
pour que le centre compte qu'il faut
qu'ils soient unis et il faut qu'il soit
indépendant
sans qu'il refuse
quand ils refusent
toute tentative et dieu sait qu'elles
sont nombreuses et qu'elle se renouvelle
régulièrement toute tentative de
soumission ou de sujétion nous nous
sommes libres nous avons l'intention de
le rester et c'est en étant libre que
nous rendrons services à la france c'est
ça qu'on atteint
comprenez-moi bien
ça n'empêche pas les alliances ça
n'empêche pas les ententes ça n'empêche
pas le travail en commun dès l'instant
que l'intérêt national est en jeu mais
pour bien travailler ensemble
il faut que chacun soit bien dans son
identité dans son histoire dans le
patrimoine et dans le projet qu'il porte
et cette réponse eh bien c'est celle que
nous avons souhaité hier que nous
faisons aujourd'hui et que nous ferons
demain à toute tentative on sait jamais
qui pourrait venir on ne sait pas d'où
pour que pour que cette famille
politique
on a besoin on a besoin
regardez la bretagne c'est ma seule
incidente la majorité politique en
bretagne depuis des années c'est une
majorité qui ne reflète pas la nature
profonde de cette région
et pourquoi cette majorité politique
s'est elle imposée parce que les femmes
et les hommes du centre n'ont pas à
assumer la mission
politique historique philosophie qui
était la leur en se laissant déportés
alors que c'est une région qui avait
peut-être là au premier rang des régions
françaises qui étaient en phase qui
était temps c'est une région qui était
parmi les régions françaises et au plus
haut point en phase avec les valeurs et
les attentes et les projets et les idées
que nous portons
voilà pourquoi je suis heureux que nous
soyons ensemble
à guidel pour la troisième année
consécutive et donc je suis pour moi
cette un moment heureux je suis sûr que
ça va être un moment fructueux en tout
cas ce sera un moment affectueux merci à
tous